en esta ocasión voy a definir recursiva
mente una secuencia aritmética así que
para empezar vamos a decir que el
término y estimo el término y eso va a
ser igual al término anterior alterno y
es uno menos uno es decir el término
anterior a éste más once eso quiere
decir que cada término será once veces
mayor que el término anterior y ahora
tenemos que establecer un caso base así
que vamos a decir que en nuestro caso
base es decir nuestro primer término me
voy a suponer que es 4 va a ser igual a
4 ok
ahora lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es encontrar la suma de los primeros 650
términos de esta secuencia entonces dada
nuestra definición recursiva de nuestra
secuencia aritmética te reto a que
encuentras la suma de los primeros 650
términos de la secuencia déjame
escribirlo queremos encontrar la suma
de él
los primeros
650 términos 650 términos
de bueno de esta secuencia entonces
dicen encontrar la suma de los primeros
650 términos de la secuencia y como
siempre te invito a que pause el vídeo y
que te imagines cómo puede funcionar
todo esto
ok entonces cómo podemos resolver esto
bueno en muchos vídeos dimos una idea
intuitiva de la suma de las secuencias
aritméticas recuerdas y obtuvimos una
fórmula para evaluar la suma de la
secuencia aritmética a la cual
llamaremos sería aritmética y esta serie
aritmética o esta suma la denotamos así
la suma de los primeros términos esto
era igual al primer término más el
último término esto dividido entre 2 muy
bien el promedio entre el primero y el
último término y esto lo multiplicamos
por la cantidad de términos
esta suma sirve cuando hablamos de una
sucesión aritmética es decir una
sucesión en la cual el siguiente termino
es igual al término anterior más una
cantidad fija entonces que hay de esta
serie que tengo aquí cuál será su primer
término cuál será su último término y
bueno cuál es el valor de n bueno pues
hasta ahorita sabemos que queremos
encontrar la suma de los primeros 650
términos por lo tanto n vale 650 muy
bien sabemos también que el primer
término es 4 así que este término de kim
es 4 y bueno la pregunta es cuánto vale
a subíndice n es decir a subíndice 650
lo que estamos buscando es el término
650 de esta sucesión aritmética y
pensemos un poco en ello si queremos
averiguar ese número observa lo
siguiente nuestro primer término
estás de acuerdo y después llegamos al
siguiente término el cual es 11 unidades
mayor que 4 es decir 4 + 11 me da 15
este es mi segundo término y quién es mi
tercer término bueno mi tercer términos
15 + 11 de nuevo lo cual me da 26 muy
bien y así me voy a mantener sumando y
sumando y sumando y sumando hasta llegar
al último término el último término es a
650 el término 650 ahora observa que el
primer término al segundo término
sumaste en una vez 11 del segundo
término al tercer término también
sumaste 11 y bueno así te vas a mantener
sumando 11 sumando 11 hasta que en un
punto para llegar al último término
también vamos a sumar 11 por última vez
pero observa lo siguiente para llegar al
segundo término lo que hicimos fue sumar
una vez 11 empezamos con el 4 y le
sumamos una vez 11
al llegar al segundo término para llegar
al tercer término le sumamos el 4 12
veces 11 para llegar al cuarto término
tendríamos que sumarle al 4 1 2 3 veces
11 y si queremos llegar al término 650
cuántas veces tenemos que sumar 11 para
llegar al término 650 bueno para llegar
al término 650 habrá que sumar 11 650
veces menos 1 es decir 600 49 veces
veces es muy fácil solo observar lo
siguiente cuando empezamos con el primer
término bueno si el primer término le
sumó una menos una vez 11
bueno uno menos 10 por 11 me queda 0 así
que el primer término no le sumamos nada
y el segundo término bueno al segundo
término le sumas de una vez 11 y al
tercer término bueno le sumas t 12 veces
11 y el cuarto término le habrá sumado
una
tres veces son cero así que al término
650 habrá que sumarle 1 2 3 649 veces 11
y por lo tanto ya podemos saber quién es
nuestro término 650 lo voy a escribir
por aquí nuestro término a subíndice 650
este tel no quién va a ser bueno pues
éste va a ser igual a 4 más 649 veces 11
649 veces 11 al primer término le vamos
a sumar 600 49 veces 11 y cuando se esto
bueno para eso voy a sacar por acá mi
calculadora y vamos a hacerlo 649 veces
11 es lo mismo que 7.139 y si a esto le
sumó 4 obtengo 7.143 así que déjame
anotarlo esto va a ser igual a 7 mil 140
y tres y de lujo era el último dato que
nos faltaba así que lo voy a sustituir
aquí esto es lo mismo que 7.143 me voy a
tomar la suma de estos dos dividirla
entre 2 y multiplicarlo por 650 así que
traigamos de nuevo mi calculadora la voy
a poner por acá y dice cuatro más siete
mil 143 esto es igual y esto entre dos
de lujo y si esto lo multiplicamos por
650 me va a dar de resultado dos
millones 322 mil 775 vaya número
voy a notarlo esta suma esta suma de los
primeros 650 términos va a ser igual a 2
millones 322 mil y bueno olvide los
demás disculpa mi mala memoria pero lo
tengo aquí 775 de lujo 775 y bueno toda
esta cantidad de aquí también la podrías
obtener haciendo todo esto a mano es más
te invito a que lo hagas recuerda que
nunca hace daño practicar un poco la
aritmética